voici mon gros my life 2 c'est pas parce
que j'ai une deuxième vie mais c'est
parce que je voulais revenir sur
certains moments de ma vie qui ont été
importants quand j'étais tout petit les
bd me fascine et j'adorais voir les
dessins mais je savais pas lire alors je
dessinais des bd avec des bulles vide
parce que je savais pas écrire alors mes
parents m'ont inscrit à un cours d'arts
plastiques dans un centre culturel à
nice j'étais trop content parce que
j'avais des feutres et des pinceaux 9
je pense que mes parents et mes bien se
dire ouais si tu veux mon fils il a une
fibre artistique qui va des cours d'arts
plastiques c'est le plus jeune du cours
eux
oui mon fils ne veut pas dessiner et il
veut plus jamais revenir au cours
d'accor
ouais si tu veux mon fils il va
commencer le piano en fait ouais il a le
sens de la mélodie clairement en fait
j'aimais pas qu'on me dise quoi et
comment dessiner et pour la blague mes
parents m'ont acheté un piano avec leurs
économies et je leur ai dit le faire de
la batterie certifié enfants relou ont
fait un bond en avant j'ai 17 ans je
suis au lycée je passe mon temps à faire
des dessins que je poste sur mon blog
suivi par quelques personnes c'est vrai
et là je découvre les sites dailymotion
et youtube on peut poster les vidéos sur
internet alors j'en parle à mes potes et
riga j'aimerais trop poster des vidéos
sur internet et ils me disent adorer
super risqué de s'afficher devant tout
le monde on va voir ton visage et tout
et puis t'as pas de caméra les parents
ont un caméscope
alors j'ai pas hésité j'ai filmé un test
de jeux musique un sketch bref tout et
n'importe quoi à trouver cyprien tu as
enregistré par dessus nos vidéos de
vacances
écoutez mère mon art est plus important
que vos vidéos fut-il un mais on avait
des cassettes vierges en fait ouais
ouais je vais faire savoir et soudain
sur mon blog
arrête les vidéos c'est la première fois
que je reçois un commentaire de ce genre
vous savez quoi je n'ai pas écouté
mais ça vous êtes au courant quelques
mois plus tard j'entre à la fac avec ce
en provence et tous mes temps libres
sont consacrés à faire des vidéos
j'en ai posté des dizaines sur mon blog
et surprise dans ma boîte aux lettres
pour en rester dans mes mails mais bon
on m'invite à paris à une convention
pour ceux qui bossent sur internet des
start up des graphistes et surtout
d'autres créateurs vidéo c'est la
première occasion pour rencontrer des
gens avec la même passion coin parce que
oui en 2007 on est très très peu
nombreux mais vraiment très peu quoi
mais la date tombe le même jour que mes
examens alors je peux pas y aller
donc j'y suis quand même allé j'ai fait
plein de rencontres et j'ai loupé mon
sommet si je sais pas si c'est le hasard
mais quelques semaines plus tard je
reçois un mail
euh pardon un mail à on me propose un
boulot de monteur vidéo sur paris c'est
super mais je suis en plein milieu de
mes études et j'ai pas de diplôme
je me rappelle d'un étudiant de ma fac
qui me disait que c'était une mauvaise
idée d'arrêter les i
dont j'ai accepté le job je suis montée
sur paris pour travailler
j'en ai déjà parlé dans mon premier
drame ilife tout en faisant des vidéos
sur ma chaîne à côté c'était en 2008
l'année où j'ai fait la rencontre de
norman hugo que marc pv nova et squeeze
non c'est pas vrai pour squeeze en 2008
il avait 12 ans prenez pas mes cris ont
fait un bond de quelques années en avant
fin 2011
je travaille sur la chaîne télé
d'histoire et de documentaires nrj 12
j'y fais une mini émission quotidienne
donc en gros je fais une vidéo chaque
jour pour la télé et le week end je fais
des vidéos pour ma chaîne youtube et
youtube vient de mettre en place un
système qui permet de rémunérer les
créateurs
parce que oui avant sur internet on
faisait des vidéos pendant des années
juste pour le plaisir
à ce moment là personne ne vit de vidéos
postées sur internet j'ai même pas 200
mille abonnés on peut pas se lancer dans
un métier qui n'existe pas alors je le
fais je pose ma démission au milieu de
la saison
mes collègues me disent que plein de
gens rêvent de bosser à la télé et que
c'est pas très judicieux de quitter ce
boulot et moi je le vois pas le risque
je vois juste du fun du temps pour faire
mes vidéos et des rencontres et ce genre
de décision je suis pas le seul à les
prendre
monter sur scène face à des milliers de
personnes fait le rencontrer le dalaï
lama fait le faire de la musique sans
instrument fait le du cinéma sans avoir
un seul contact fait le expliquer
l'inexplicable fait le aujourd'hui je
repense à tous les commentaires qui
peuvent paraître décourageant et ça me
donne encore plus envie d'avancer d'être
créatif et j'ai enfin trouvé quoi mettre
dans la bulle de mon petit personnage si
ça te paraît impossible
fais-le quand même
[Musique]